you
play with the machine level 8 let's see
your 2500 this time control real-time 3
- boom alright stockfish Knight f3
alrighty let's see what you got let's
see hmm
alright let's just develop Bishop g5 mm
let's push now I'm gonna take Bishop d3
or Bishop e2 I'm just gonna go one step
yeah sidestep oh they're not even going
there I want to go to I went to e2 just
to avoid c5 I didn't want to take and I
didn't want to run into c4 with tempo on
my bishop so I guess the idea now is
this whatever I'll let you do it
alright let's back up
Knight b6 huh interesting
well I guess they preparing to get the
bishop out let's play Queen c2 sure let
me do this huh Wow
really this computer doesn't know what
it's doing just freely giving me the
bishop pair I've got zero compensation
for that this is where you go down give
me that guy oh that is a cool idea
nice the thread is g5 and then chop chop
and I got a weak link on III so I at the
end of the day I'm gonna have to return
this guy that is very cool I learned
something right then and you know I
think I've had this happen to me before
playing against computer so I think I
have to take the knight is what I'm
getting at otherwise g5 is too strong I
can't allow this on to become backward
unprotected so I think I have to cash
out now ideally I'd like to have this
guy here in the bishop back but that
would hang the bishop
maybe this first at least for the time
being I'm controlling ye or excuse me c4
you know let's get this guy here okay so
lining up this kind of stuff huh if I do
this this he's unprotected but waking up
I'm gonna be sacrifices here that were
coming over I don't have any time
actually we're gonna try this instead I
don't need to make this move just yet
it's Queen here get my queen over really
it's that about okay I think I know what
that's about
when offer a queen exchange Queen takes
pawn queen d6 g3 rook takes here let's
expand here Wow
I gotta go faster huh
wouldn't you say wouldn't you say
Wow computers flying now trying for time
burners and stuff I'm happy to see that
move
let's take challenge mm-hmm King here I
don't know how I want to take there oh
I'm in so much trouble
yeah the bishops strong man strong real
strong gotta get rid of that bishop and
he's not going anywhere I'm dropping
this guy ouch and this guy like dominoes
they fall yipper I got a passed pawn you
got a couple to yourself though yeah
yeah it's just how it is he's way too
fast out Tundra zone Wow
this right here let me just show you why
did not take this pawn it's because of
this and if I do this chop here is a
good mate in one - I couldn't really
voice it because I needed to go fast
even positioned up till when even even
even even this was instructive to me h3
just giving up the bishop and then
playing Bishop d6 oh I don't have to
this has suggested 92 meeting Bishop g5
with here and then I could recapture
some other move let's just say this runs
into g5 it's going a little screwy now
maybe if I shut it off and turn it back
on that really worked okay no there we
go it did work g5 here this is just
terrible 94 queenie saw between d6g
threes weak rook here it's just a bad
structure this is weakened to the for
the black king but
very very difficult to exploit this is I
would definitely prefer to play as black
here you know so yeah I didn't even
consider this move 92
if g5 here if takes I'm recapturing like
this and then this starts to be a
serious issue my structure remains quite
good and I could try to pounce on these
squares this didn't even come to mind
hmm 92 and then well I was gonna say I'm
better but I mean it's still even
evaluation wise but I'll have a bishop
that's well coordinated with my my pawn
structure and I could slowly look to do
this this stuff over here it'll be
around to watch over c4 when this
minority attack comes about it's tough
to get this minority attack in if I'm
without my light square bishop because
the knight will pounce right here and c4
right away you know okay well 92 I'll
remember that for next time
still even
still even be three huh
they're starting to pull ahead they have
some queenside space it's still sort of
even h4 was probably wrong because I'm
he eventually fell right yeah h4 I'm
looking for h5 to break down the
structure some but puts a halt to it
this is this is a poor idea it's calling
for h4 but oh I don't know this little
rear out of the bishop was fantastic
as soon as soon as the minor piece can
put pressure on b2 one of my rooks is
restricted if there's an open file black
is close to doing what exactly making
use of that open file entering the
second and that's exactly what happened
it still has it as even but when that
bishops on f6 it's really game over yeah
now it's approaching a pawn advantage
this is too strong I don't see check
here look at the rook activity I'm just
tied down I wants to bring the knight
back minus one now it's just lost okay
well let's try let's try another one
it's the machine um yeah I guess I'll
play is black oh let's try this okay
take it into the French alright
c5 okay
try to get rid of my bad Bishop Bishop
b2 Bishop d3 and still didn't go here
alright so I got rid of my bad bishop
that's nice let's come back here I feel
like I just want to take right now but
let's not do that just yeah let's
develop so I want my knight here my
bishop here if there's ever g4 I'd like
to play Knight h4 follow but if I do
this right now
pawn takes I need to take first ooh
taking with the knight so actually I
could actually think about coming here
with my queen Knight yeah let's take two
minor pieces against the space
disadvantage I should be able to work
with that get him here trying to play a
good versus bad Bishop situation I think
that this is just even I think my
opponents also playing too fast like I
don't know how to play chess it's just
say you know none of my moves are good
it just plays fast you know none of my
moves are good man just doesn't have to
think you got nothing you got nothing
I'll just take your knight this can't be
bad man it can't be bad okay so this is
your big plan your big plan is to stop
me from diploid developing my Bishop but
what if I do this or what if I do this
and then here at least I could drop my
pawn like that
h5 the Queen will probably just back up
maybe it's still a good idea I don't
know g6 I'm a bit fearful of this in the
this stuff opening up here here castles
what I want to get in before something
is opened up on the Queen side here and
here I'm threatening this pawn maybe
maybe not well
I got it I got a completely kingside
development okay so yeah I've no fear no
fear let's do this let's castle hmm huh
maybe I don't want a castle just yeah
what about Age 5 let's go h5 hmm
stop queen bee five okay
now Castle I have to be mindful of this
advance but that would weaken here okay
no probably this rook here or what about
b5 b5 seems pretty good let's go with b5
whoo and then let's go rook here
preparing to just get my bishop here Wow
Wow hmm don't have much time
bishop f8 pawn takes takes rook takes
rook takes and they went upon I think I
have to take like this which makes him
super vulnerable yeah actually I'm just
losing that now huh
so I guess in the end I'm dropping upon
or yeah they have enough on this huh
maybe I could get a perpetual somehow oh
they must have saw some something
they're afraid of something huh because
I'm holding this pawn now ooh what's
that about
no look here defend my seventh here
Queen trade can I get it to draw here
I gotta go here hmm
space I'm gonna get a passed pawn okay I
think this is a draw hmm because if the
King approaches I could start pushing
with this guy I just want to be really
careful about when I start pushing let's
come back here it goes too far
push let's come back here
gotta give checks and come back over
check come back over this is certainly a
draw they know that they could give up
material cause it's gonna still hold as
a draw right I know your tricks man it's
a draw
sneaky sneaky sneaky sneaky I don't have
an answer to why they didn't go after
that pond like right here like why was
this nut picked up in this position
right here rook takes pawn Oh an
in-betweener I could take first though
too because if it takes I take here you
take me I take you uh-huh
and that felt like an even game right
out of the opening this is an inch
idea those of you that are familiar with
the French defense know that this is a
bad guy right here he's your bad guy
he's a good guy so this idea of not
being so quick with the natural 96 Queen
b6 Bishop d7 Bishop beef b5 it takes a
lot of moves but at least gets rid of
your Bishop and then well you gonna look
to play it like I did really this good
versus bad Bishop situation and yeah
they were really helpful to me in a way
where I was able to play with this space
disadvantage but I only had two minor
pieces in exchanging off a knight and
having a perfectly good square in c6
this is this is even it confirms it with
the evaluation g6 I already felt like I
might have been close to better right
around here yeah right around here I
felt like I could have done something
better b5 it wants to go rook c8 I think
that's what I want to do first
it likes rook FBA at b5 I thought if
this they take here mmm
what just happened there I know someone
did a an analysis of it that says even a
game as you're gonna get there it is oh
my god six zeros you see that that's
pretty crazy
yeah I thought on this let's see this
again takes takes takes takes and then
they're winning this prawn how is it
even check ah
keeping the Queen's on the board
recognizing the White has the more
vulnerable King this is also a threat
you see you'll see a change in the
evaluation if I take now it's a troop on
and there's no fear for the white side
this is not a good structure for white
if the Queen's are on the board if the
Queen's are off the board it's a
perfectly fine structure well they're
potentially vulnerable to my bishop you
know okay cool I thought I could have
easily gone wrong right around here
though it was way low on time way low I
thought I was losing after King here I
thought this move kills me but I have
this yeah Wow and yeah it's important to
keep pressure on this pawn whenever it
gets to a point where white is defending
here with the King I got it I gotta do
something about that I gotta kick him
out cannot allow the rook to move with
check and then do this I have to
constantly keep pressure on that
and yeah alright also I did not want to
be too quick to push this connected past
pond I only wanted to push him at a
point where I knew the White King would
not be able to hunt him down so for
example in this position right well
that's why I did a move like this rook
to b3 I'm cutting the King off if he
goes over here then I could start
pushing and yeah white I'll have to come
back with the rook and then I could take
here and there's no fear alright GG
stock fish